next question the next question comes from
motorola 15g ace all right in the new earth made
new will we be living in houses being made by man
let's pray again father in heaven as we continue
continue to grant us wisdom all of us i pray in
jesus name amen john 14 1-3 let not your heart be
troubled you believe in god believe also me in my
father's house are many mansions if it were not so
i would have told you i go to prepare a place
for you christ is god we know there's a city
that's coming down from heaven you know there's
a space station up in the up in the sky somewhere
people have lived there for years there now god
can build a city in space it's coming down and
god's been released in that city will also live in
the countryside so yes there'll be little houses
have what they will look like we don't know but
they'll be literal houses you live in life in the
new world is not as kind of a floating around like
disembodied ghosts that's not what it is it is a
literal three-dimensional existence even christ
will be three-dimensional he will always keep this
human form and since you have human form you need
a three-dimensional world in order to function and
have meaning and so yes life will there will be
houses you'll plant your vineyards the bible says
you you eat from them we'll have things to do we
don't know all the details but it will be a life
the major difference is or the major difference
is we see god face to face and there is no sin
there is no sin but as verily as heaven is a
busy place where angels have the responsibilities
and they're traveling back and forth we
will have our duties in the new world so
yes there'll be a real life but the details
have been hidden from us most of them
get there that's the important thing
and whatever happens there you'll like it
amen amen